Hey, what's up YouTube, my name is Jake Krieger.
And this is exactly what you think it is, it's
an introduction to flask for Python. So, this is
what we're going to be doing here, I'm pretty much
going to start from the ground up, and we're going
to go through each building block of flask until
we have created a basic crud application, it's not
going to be anything too special, don't get Don't
get excited, it's just going to be a little like
to do task master app. And then finally, we'll
top it off by deploying to Heroku. I feel like I
should mention now before we continue on here that
this tutorial does assume some prior knowledge
of Python, how Python code is written. It also
assumes you know, HTML CSS, you don't have to know
it too well. For this tutorial, we don't write
a whole lot. But knowing how to write a basic
HTML page would certainly be helpful. Otherwise,
it's pretty bare bones, you should be able to
follow along pretty easily if you know how to
write code in general. Alright, so this is what
we're actually going to be making here. A little
application called task master, it's basically
just a to do list. Alright, as you can see, it
says you have no new tasks, create one below. So
let's do that. Do the dishes. So as you can see,
it pops up in a little table, here, we've got our
task, the date, it was added in some actions. So
we've got a delete action and an update action.
Let's go ahead and check out the update action
here brings us to a new page where we can do
exactly what you would think, update the task. So
I'm just gonna go ahead and change this to do the
dishes and the laundry, click Update. And there
you go, it's updated in the table, do the dishes
and the laundry. And then if we had completed it,
and we don't want it on our list anymore, we can
just click Delete. There it goes. Alright, so
that's what we're going to be creating. Alright,
so let's start with setting up our environment.
So we need to install Python, obviously 3.6. or
newer, I believe the current version is 3.7 point
something. And then we're going to install the
virtual and virtual environment package from Pip.
We're going to create our project directory,
setup folders, all of that, create a virtual
environment. And then we're going to install the
required packages. And that should be enough to
get us going. So let's do that. So we'll start by
just typing in Python into Google here, head over
to python.org. Go to download and just click the
link. If you're on Mac or Linux, you have Python
installed already. It should be python 2.7. I
don't remember if Python three comes installed
already. But as you can see, I have Python 2.7
installed. And I also have Python 3.6 point one,
so I'm good. And this is how you check your
current version here. If you're on Mac or Linux,
the command corresponds to the version. So you
use Python if you want to use Python 2.7 and
use the Python three command if you want to use
Python three if you haven't installed. And this
is the same for PIP you use PIP if you're
installing packages for Python two, and you
use PIP three if you're installing packages for
Python three. Alright, so I already have Python
installed. So I don't have to click download.
The next thing we need to do is actually set
up our work environment. So I'm in Visual Studio
code here. Use whatever text editor ID you like,
I would strongly recommend Visual Studio Code
though I think it's by far the most powerful,
the easiest to use quickest workflow. Anyways,
I'm going to go ahead and click open folder
here. I'm just going to go ahead and actually,
I'm already in my projects folder. So this is
fine. But this wherever you'd like, I'm gonna
go ahead and call this flask introduction. And
then just click Open. And then I can close that.
And then hit Ctrl tilde a to open up a terminal
here in our current folder. And I'm going to
go ahead and type PIP three, install, whoops,
virtual ENB virtual env. And I already have this
installed. So this is going to go really quick,
you most likely won't. And this is going to be
what allows us to create a virtual environment
here. And if you're wondering why we do that,
and don't just install the packages globally,
it's so that if we wanted to work with
other people, if we wanted to, you know,
work on a project collaborate. It makes it so
that all of the requirements all the packages
that are needed, are contained within the project
itself and not on your system. In other words,
So you can transfer the project around and
everyone can just install the requirements into
the working directory and have the exact setup
that you had. So it makes it easier to work with
other people. And that's that's pretty much the
gist of it. So that's what we're gonna do. So now
that we have virtual and installed, we're gonna go
ahead and type virtual whoops, virtual and E and
V, and E and v is the name, as you can see, just
popped up here, that could really be any name,
you want u and v is the convention, it's
short, you'll have to type it. So Alright,
next up, we need to activate the environment.
So we're going to go ahead and type source,
NV bin and activate and hit Enter. And as you can
see, this little E and V in parentheses appeared.
That's how we know we are now inside of our
virtual environment. So anything we do, or install
for Python will be contained inside of this
environment and won't install anywhere globally
on our system. So let's go ahead and install the
requirements. So just go into PIP three, install,
and we need flask. And we need flask whoops, flask
SQL alchemy, like that, I'm gonna go ahead and hit
Enter. And that's going to install everything
we need. Alright, now that that's installed,
I'm going to go ahead and create a new file here,
I'm going to call it app.pi. I'm going to hit
Enter. And I'm going to go ahead and start writing
a very, very basic, the most basic flask app you
can write, but it's going to give us an outline
for the entire application. So before I do that,
just so you guys can see, I'm going to go ahead
and up the font size, I think 18 should be pretty
big. Yeah, that works. Okay, so the first thing we
need to do is import flask. So we're going to type
from flask, import flask with a capital F. Next,
we need to set up our application. So we're going
to go ahead and type AB equals flask. And then in
here, we're going to put underscore, underscore,
name, underscore, underscore. And that's just
referencing this file. So next up, we need to
create a index route so that when we browse to the
URL, we don't immediately just 404. And in flask,
you set up routes with the app route decorator.
So app dot route. And then in here, you're just
going to pass in the URL string of your route.
And we're gonna hit Enter. And then we're going
to define the function for that route. So we're
just going to call this index. And for now,
we're just going to return a string. So hello,
world. And then finally, we're going to type
if underscore underscore name, whoops, equals
equals, underscore, underscore, main underscore,
underscore, app, run. And then for now, we're
going to set debugging equal to true. So if we
have any errors, they'll pop up on the web page,
and we can see. So that's pretty much it. That
is a very basic flask application, if we run this,
it should work, it should pull up a page that says
hello world. So let's go ahead and see if that is
the case. Come down to my terminal. And I'm going
to execute this with Python three. So I'm going to
type Python three, app. Pi, come on. There we go.
And starts up a web server here. So just localhost
and then the Port 5000. And there you go. Hello,
world. So as you could tell, it's pretty boring so
far. So let's spice it up. Let's, let's talk about
static content. We'll go over some templates,
we'll go over how to use CSS and JavaScript. So
let's create some new folders. Here, we're going
to create two, we're going to call the first
one static. And then we're going to make one more
and we're going to call this templates. And we're
going to go up to here at our import. And we're
going to also import render underscore template.
So let's create a new file in here, we're going
to call it index dot HTML. And come over to here,
we're going to change this from return string
to return render template. We're gonna call that
file index dot HTML. And you don't have to specify
the folder. The name is that name for a reason it
knows to look in that folder. So it's just the
name of the file. We're just gonna create some
boilerplate HTML here. Just type Hello, world two.
So we know our template is what we're seeing and
not that string anymore. So as you can see down
here, it's automatically updating so we should
be able to refresh and see We are now reading
from our template hello world two. Alright,
so let's talk about template inheritance. Now,
if you don't know what that is, it's basically,
you create one master HTML file that that contains
kind of the the skeleton of what each page is
going to look like. And then you just inherit
that in each other page, and insert code where
you need it. But it's it basically makes it so
you don't have to write this every single time,
you only have to write like this, and this what's
relevant. So if that didn't make sense, go ahead
and show you how it's done. Call it base dot html.
Alright, so this is going to be our skeleton. So
let's create the boilerplate code here. And then
I'm just going to get rid of this title. And I'm
going to create a block I'm going to call it head.
And I'm going to whoops. And the block. Alright,
so What's this doing? This is Jinja. To syntax.
This is a template engine that flask uses. So
basically, what we're doing here is we're
creating a block in the template. And this
block is where we're going to insert our code on
all the other pages that inherit this template. So
this is pretty much outlining where we're going to
insert our own code for each page. So I'm going to
make one more and I'm going to call this body.
And then I'm going to come over to index here,
I'm going to get rid of all of this. And I'm going
to come up here, whoops, and type extends. And
then in quotes, I'm going to put the name of the
base template here, then I'm going to copy these
blocks that Enter, Enter. There we go. Okay, so
now, I can put whatever I want here. So let's
create a Hey, so let's create a h1. And we'll just
say, template. Sure. And now, if I load this up,
we should see template. So that's not all that
special. You probably think that seems like a lot
of work just to get pretty much what we just had.
But this is all you have to do for every page for
pretty much the rest of your website. As long as
it follows this format, then that includes things
like linking stylesheets and scripts that can all
be done over here. So you only ever have to do it
once. I just realized I had the the header in
the head tag here. My bad. should still work.
Yep. Okay. All right. So now that we got templates
work in here, let's go ahead and talk about static
content. So I'm gonna go over to our static
folder, I'm gonna make a new folder in here,
called CSS. I'm gonna make a new file, and call
it main dot CSS. And I'm just gonna put some basic
rule sets in here. So body. Alright, there we
go. So just getting rid of the margin setting the
font family to Sancerre. Let's go ahead and link
this in our base HTML. So we're going to do link
REL. All right, and then in the URL here, we can't
just type something like static CSS main dot CSS,
this won't work. So what do we have to do, we
have to use some more Jinja two syntax here.
If you remember before, who actually it's in his
page, we were using the bracket percent. This is
for stuff like if else statements for loops. And
these are for things you want to be printed in,
I guess strings. So this is basically going
to take the code you write in here, and it's
going to give you the the result of that as a
string. So we need to use a function from flask
called URL for and I don't know if we have to do
this, but I'm gonna go ahead and do it anyways,
just import URL for and then I'm going to put
parentheses here. And then I'm going to put in
quotes here single quotes because this is a double
quote. I'm going to put the name of the static
folder static. I'm going to type file name, equals
and then more single quotes. And I'm going to type
the name of the file and you have to include any
subdirectories in this. So since it's static CSS,
main dot CSS, we have to put that in the file
name. So CSS slash main dot CSS. And that should
be enough to link that stylesheet. So let's go
ahead and see. And there you go. Sans Serif,
no margin, it's right up against the edge is
linking our stylesheet. And this is the exact
same thing for JavaScript Do you it would just be
file name equals j s slash main j. s, if that was
the name of your JavaScript that you're trying
to link. Alright, so that does it for the basic
flask application. All right, I think we're ready
to talk about databases now. So I'm gonna go ahead
and import SQL alchemy. So from flask, underscore
SQL alchemy, import SQL alchemy. Alright,
let's go under our app here. And we're going to
add a config. And this is going to be SQL alchemy
database URL. So this is telling our app where
our database is located. And we're just going
to be using SQL Lite. There are lots of resources
online for showing you how to do this with MySQL,
or Postgres, or whatever you want to use. But just
to keep things simple, we're just going to use SQL
Lite. So we're just going to go ahead and type SQL
eight, colon, and then three forward slashes for
forward slashes is an absolute path. Three is
a relative path, we want a relative path here,
because I don't want to have to specify an
exact location, I just want it to reside in
the project location. So I'm just going to go
ahead and call this test.db. So that's what our
database is going to be everything is going to
be stored in this test.db file. And then finally,
we need to initialize our database. So we're just
going to type SQL alchemy app, pass in our app
like that. So our database has been initialized
with the settings from our app. Alright,
so that's initializing the database. Now we need
to create a model here. So we're going to make a
class and I'm just going to call this to do and
this is a DB dot model like that. give myself
another new line there. Alright, now that we've
got our class, let's set up some columns. So the
first one we need is an ID column, this is just
going to be an integer that references the ID of
each entry. So this is of type DB column, and then
this is an integer. And so this is going to be our
primary key. So we're going to set primary key
equals to true. And then we're going to create a
text column here called content. And this is just
going to be what holds each task. So this will be
DB dot string. And then I'll say 200 characters,
I think is a good amount. And then I'm going to
set nullable equal to false, because we don't want
this to be left blank, we don't want the user to
be able to create a new task, and then just leave
the content of that task empty. So then finally,
we just need one more called date created. And
this is more for bookkeeping than anything,
it's not something the user really needs access
to. So this is going to be DB dot date time
like that with the capital T. And then we're
going to set the default here. Got to come up
to the top real quick and import date time. So
from date, time, import date, time. And then
we're gonna set the default equal to date,
time, UTC now, okay. Alright, so basically,
any time and new to do entry is created, the date
created will just automatically be set to the
time that it was created. So this we don't ever
have to set manually, it'll always just be set
automatically. Alright, and then finally, we just
need a function that's going to return a string
every time we create a new element. So we're gonna
go ahead and tell it what to return here. And we
want it to return task. And then we'll just call
self.id. So every time we make a new element,
it's just going to return task and then the idea
of that task that's just been created. And that
does it for our model here. So let's go ahead
and set up the database. Now. We're gonna head
down to the terminal. And I'm going to just type
actually, first I have to activate my environment.
So let's do that. We begin, activate. There we
go. Okay, so now that our environments activated,
we can go ahead and just start a interactive
Python three shell So I'm going to type from app
import dB. So this is going to go ahead and import
into our interactive shell, this DB object up
here. So then we're just going to type DB create,
underscore all. And that should create a database.
And you can see it popped up right over here. So
then we can exit out of that. And now we have our
database setup. If you remember from earlier,
I showed you that task master application,
we're going to go ahead and create that now.
Alright, so in our index dot HTML file here,
let's go ahead and get rid of this header. And
I'm going to go ahead and set up a div here. I'm
just going to call this content. And then we're
going to make a header, just call us or just have
the say task master. And I'm going to come down
here, I'm going to make a table. Let's create a
table row, table header task. And then added for
the date that it was created. And then actions,
oops. Okay, so that's, those are the three columns
we'll have. And then I'm just going to leave this
empty for now we'll come back to this. Actually,
you know what, I'm going to do this, I'm going
to create another row. And then I'm not going
to put anything in here and make another one,
I'm gonna make one more. And then I'm going to add
two links here. And I'm going to leave these empty
for now. Just have the, say, delete. Add a break
here, and paste one more in and this one will say,
update. Okay, so let's go ahead and run our server
here and see what we've got now. Okay, so there
we go. So as taskmaster, we've got a table. And
we've got some links here for the actions, delete,
and update. Alright, so let's head on over to
app.pi here. And we're going to come down to our
index and we need to change something, we need to
come up into our decorator. And after the route,
we're going to add an option called methods. And
then we're gonna set this equal to list here,
and this is going to be post in quotes, and then
get in quotes. So this is adding two methods that
this route can accept. Now instead of just get by
default, we can now post to this route as well and
send data to our database, which is exactly what
we want to do. So let's head over to our index
file here. And then under table, we're going to
add a form. And we're just going to set the action
URL to our index. And then method equals whoops,
post. Alright, and then let's create two inputs,
we're gonna have a text input and a submit input.
So text, set the name equal to content. And the ID
is also content. And the input again, type is
submit value, add task. Alright, so those are
our two inputs for form, just go ahead and look
at this. And it updated. But everything is now
all messed up. That's okay, we'll fix that later.
not worried about it right now. All that matters
is that and we've now got the form that we need.
All right, so let's go over this one more time.
Nothing in the head tag for now, we can actually,
we can add a title, if you want, I'll just call
this task master. update this and yeah, it says
task master. Okay, so that doesn't matter. You
can put whatever you want there. But uh, got a
div here, called content. header, taskmaster,
you could say whatever you'd like. And then we're
just creating a table. So I'm going to collapse
this for now. So we can get the whole thing in
there. So these are headers task added in actions,
and then we've got one more row. And we've just
kind of written the skeleton for this for now,
because this is going to be where each new task is
added. So this is going to be updated dynamically,
which we haven't gotten to yet, but we will in
just a moment. Alright, that's pretty much it
for the HTML for now. So let's head back to our
app.py file. And then we're going to come down
to our index route here and we're gonna we're
gonna Change this a little bit. So we're gonna
start with an if statement if request dot method
equals equals post. So this is going to say if
the request that's set to this route is post, do
stuff there, and then else, do more stuff. So this
is pretty much what we're looking at if post, this
is how we're going to grab the task and put it in
our database. Otherwise, we're just pretty much
looking at the page. So under else here, we can
actually just put render template and just have
it show us our page. So this should work. Well,
it won't, because we're not running it. So let's
do that first. Alright, name error request is not
defined, come up to our import here, and we just
need to import that. And that should fix that. And
there we go. So it's still just showing us our
page. And then, if we were to submit that form,
type error, the view function did not return
a valid response, because we're not actually
returning anything. If I set this to return Hello,
that should do exactly what it says. It'll return
Hello, if we submit our form, otherwise, it's just
going to show us our page. So we've set that up.
So let's go ahead and actually put our logic for
adding a task in here, let's create a variable,
we're gonna call this task content. And then
that request object again, form for that form
we created. And then we're just going to pass
in the ID of the input that we want to get the
contents of which was content. So test content is
equal to the contents of this input right here.
So then I'm just going to go ahead and create a
model for this. As you can see, our we have our
to do model. So let's create a to do object that's
going to have its contents equal to the content of
that input. So now we've got our to do model, all
that's left to do is push it to our database. So
we're going to try DB dot session dot add. So
we're adding this to our database session, this
new task, then we want to commit so DB dot session
dot commit, commit that to our database. And then
finally, we just need to return. And we're going
to return a redirect back to our index, which we
have to come back up to our import again, and now
we're going to import redirect. So it's going to
create a new task from that input, it's going to
try to commit it to our database, and then it's
going to redirect us back to our index page. If
that does happen to fail, just create an accept
here and we're just going to return there was an
issue, adding your test. So just a plain string,
with the error message here is all we really
need. This should, generally speaking, never fail,
but just in case it does. And then we're going
to come down to lcwr. And we're going to create
a variable called tasks, set this to a to do query
order, underscore by to do dot date created. So
what is this, this is going to look at all of the
database contents in the order they were created.
And it's just going to return all of them. So
we're just querying our database or ordering them
by the date created, so newest to oldest and then
we're just grabbing all of them. You could also do
first to grab the first, which would be the most
recent if we're sorting by date, we're just going
to grab them all. And this is how we're going to
display all the current tasks in that table. And
then we need to pass this to our template. And
we're just going to set tasks equal to tasks,
that variable we just created. And that does it
for our index form. So let's head on over to the
index dot HTML. And we just need to add some quick
code here. We're going to come down to this row,
I'm going to indent this. And then we're going to
do some Jinja to syntax here. And then we're just
going to type for task in tasks. And this is going
to grab all of the tasks in that task variable we
passed to this template. And then we just need to
end the four. So we're just going to come up to
our first TD tag here and we're going to do double
curly braces. And we're just going to type task
content. So this is going to return the content
of Each task. And then we're just gonna do one
more for the date created. And then we're just
going to do dot date. So it doesn't return the
time as well, because if you remember, it's a date
time object right here, date time, we just need
the date. So a created date. And then over here,
we actually haven't set up our delete route yet,
so I'm gonna leave that alone. But if I go ahead
and start up our app here, could see our table
disappears. So let's go ahead and add a task.
And as you can see, it pops up in our table.
So the Delete and update don't do anything yet.
But as you can see, pushing to our database is
currently working. So we've got the Create part
of our crud app done. So I'm just real quick,
I'm going to copy over some CSS to clean up this
page a little bit as it's kind of just kind of not
very attractive sitting there all the way in the
corner like that. Alright, so let me refresh here.
And there we go. So that's kind of what we were
looking at originally, I'm actually going to go
ahead and just do this real quick. Go ahead and
send her a line that text. So there we go. Okay,
so that's, that's what we had earlier. Alright, so
now that we've got the Create part done, let's go
ahead and do the Delete part, because that's the
next easiest. So let's head over to our app.pi.
And we need to set up a new route for this. So I'm
just going to come under index one here, app that
route, and then it's going to be slash delete. And
then we need to get the ID, this number right here
is going to be the easiest way of identifying
a unique task. Because if we go by content or
anything like that, this kind of content can
be the same for multiple passes. So we need a
unique identifier, which is what this primary
keys here for, this will always be unique, you
can never have a duplicate. So come over to here,
slash delete slash, and then we're going to put in
a bracket here, int for integer, colon, and then
the name of the variable. So we're just gonna call
this ID. And then that's it for that. Alright,
so then let's just find our function here. We'll
call it elite, passing ID as the variable
that we need. And then we're ready to go.
So let's go ahead and create a variable for the
task that we want to delete. So task to delete,
and then we're going to query our database here.
And we're going to do get, so dot query dot get
underscore or underscore 404 ID. So this is going
to attempt to get that task by the ID. And if it
doesn't exist, it's just going to four or four. So
then let's do a try. Then we're going to do DB dot
session dot delete. And then we're going to pass
in task to delete. Whoops, didn't mean to do that,
then we're going to come on to there, and we need
to commit this again, commit. And then we're going
to return a redirect back to our homepage. And
then if this doesn't work, we'll just print
another string with our error message. So there
was a problem, deleting that task. Alright. So
that is our delete route. And this should actually
work. I think we're good here. Let's go ahead and
run our app again. And we've got this task in
here. Actually, no real quick, we do have to
come over to our delete. So let's do slash delete.
And then double brackets here, because we want to
get the ID of that current task. So task.id. And
that should, if we hover over this, you can see
down at the bottom left there in the browser, so
slash delete slash one, so it's getting the idea
of this task. So if we click Delete, disappears,
there we go. So that's the Delete. All right,
on to updating. So let's make one more route here.
I'm gonna call it app dot route, slash update,
slash. And we're going to do the same thing and
ID. So we're gonna grab the ID of the task we
want to update. And then methods. And we need to
do the same thing as earlier with our index route,
because we're going to be posting. So let's go
ahead and do that. And then let's go ahead and
create the function. So update ID. And then return
for now just return nothing. Let's come over to
our index here, and we're going to copy this,
paste it down here and instead of slash delete,
we'll change this to slash update. And then
we're going to make one more template here and
we're going to call this update dot html. And
we're going to just copy our index HTML here,
we're going to get rid of this table. Because we
don't need to show all of our tasks, we just want
to show the one that we're updating, change this
to update task. So then the action will be slash
update, slash. And then we'll grab that, whoops.
hask Id like that. Okay, so this should be our
update page, we're gonna go over to our update
route, I'm going to do if request dot method
equals post, pass, because we'll add our code
in a minute here else, return render, template,
update. html. Okay. So there we go. I'm just gonna
go ahead and run this real quick. And make sure
that if we go to, we need to make a new test task
here, the update page. Okay, so it did work. It's
returning an error task is undefined because I've
called task ID. But if you notice in our function
here, I'm not actually sending a variable called
task. So let's come down. Actually, we'll do it up
here, we'll create a variable called task equals
to do query. Think I typed that, right? Yep. That,
actually, we could just copy this whole thing.
Okay, there we go. So same thing as the Delete,
we're grabbing the task. We're just getting the
task from the ID here, because we're passing that
into the URL, then we'll come down to here, and
we'll pass that into our render template function
here. And now this should work. There we go. So
it's not grabbing the text from our task. As you
can see, it says do the dishes in the laundry.
When we click Update, that's not in here. So
let's auto populate that, come over to update.
And then we'll set the value of this input this
text input to grab this instead of task that it or
ID task content. So now that should, there we go
show the text of the task. So then we want when we
click Update, or well doesn't say update, because
we have to change that here. forgot about that.
So there we go. Now if we click Update, it's not
doing anything, the view function did not return
a valid response. Because if you remember, we're
just doing a pass here. So let's go ahead and add
our update logic is actually pretty easy. Task
content equals request. form content. actually
got this wrong past content, not task underscore
content, equals request frm. So we're just setting
this current tasks content to be content in this
forum's input box. And then we just need to try
DB dot session commit. And we don't have to add
or delete or anything, we just have to commit
because we set the content right here. So we're
not adding a new one, we're just updating. And
then we need to do a return redirect back to our
homepage. And that's it for that. So unexpected
into Oh, it forgot our exception here. Return
there was an issue updating your task. Alright.
should be good now. Yep. That mean to open
Chrome. Let's go ahead and update this task. So
let's just change do the dishes and the laundry,
and brush your teeth. And click Update. And there
you go. So we are now updating our task. Let's go
ahead and make another task here. So we can see
that there are multiple entries popping up in
this box here, do the dishes and E some broccoli.
Definitely didn't spell that right. Brock. Oh,
Lee, we're going with we're going with two L's
add task. So there we go. And then we can update
all of these individually. Let's change that to
banana. Eat some banana. Doesn't make sense, but
it doesn't need to because we can just delete it.
I'm going to delete that. And I'm going to delete
that. And now we have nothing. So I'm going to add
one more thing to our index page. I'm going to add
an if statement. And Jinja to syntax. Alright,
and this is going to say if tasks. And then
we're going to do a filter here. This is a Jinja
to filter. It's called length He's going to get
us the length of that list. And if it's less
than one, so if there are no entries in it, we
will go ahead and create one more here. And it's
just going to say else. So if there are entries,
we want to show this table. But if there aren't
any entries, we want to just show a header here
that says there are no tasks, create one below.
And then close off that. And then we'll just copy
this center style here for that as well. So now, I
think this is still updating, encountered unknown
tag and to block because we didn't end our if. So
let's grab this end for here. Come under table.
And then change this from end to end if and now
we should be good. There are no tests create one
below looks like there's some formatting issues
for not totally sure how I managed to do that,
but should be good now. Okay, there we go. And
then if we make a new task, do the dishes add
task that goes away, now we see our table. So I
believe that's everything, we've got everything
working. So that is a basic crud app. All right.
So finally, let's talk about pushing to Heroku.
If you don't know what Heroku is, I'll go ahead
and show you go to Heroku comm it's pretty much a
service that lets you host any number of different
web apps, whether it's Node JS, Ruby on Rails,
PHP, Python, that could be Django flask, what have
you. And they'll they'll host your app for you and
pretty much run it off their own servers and not
your own. So you can also create databases through
them. And it pretty much makes it really easy to
manage and run a web app without having to set up
your own web server. So I already have an account,
if you don't just go ahead and click Sign up and
sign up for free, they have a free tier, you will
have to use your credit card if you want to add
any of their database functionality. But since we
were just using SQL lite, we don't have to worry
about that. So free tier is fine. So yeah, just go
ahead and sign up. And then once you've signed up,
go ahead and look up Heroku CLR, we need the
command line interface here. And it's that first
link, just go ahead and click that come down to
download and install here. And you can see there
are installers for whatever system you're on.
So just go ahead and install that. And then once
that's installed, let's head down to our terminal
here and type in Heroku log in. And that's going
to pull this up, I've already logged in before, so
it knows my email if you probably haven't before,
so just go and type your sin and enter, type your
password, hit Enter, and it should log you in just
like that. Alright, now that that's done, let's go
ahead and create an empty Git repository. I feel
like I should mention that you do need Git. If you
don't have Git installed, just go ahead and go to
get dash SCM comm and install it off of there. And
then once that's installed, you'll be able to use
the Git command line as well. Actually, before we
do that, we need to freeze our requirements. And
actually, before we do that, we need to install a
dependency. So let's go ahead and make sure you're
in your virtual environment here, we're going to
type PIP three, install, and it's called gunicorn,
Jiyu. And I corn, hit Enter. And go ahead and let
that install should go pretty quick. And then you
can go ahead and freeze your requirements.
So PIP three, freeze requirements dot txt,
and that's going to spit out all the requirements
in a txt file here. And now that we're done with
that, we can go ahead and initialize an empty Git
repository. So Git init. So initialized, empty Git
repository, git add and then period just to add
everything in the directory. And then that's done.
So then we need to commit, I'll just say in the
app for the comment here. And then that's going
to commit everything to the repository. So now
we can finally create our Heroku app. So Heroku,
create. And then your application name, this can
only be lowercase letters, can only have dashes
and numbers. So we're just going to create one
called flask, crud app tutorial, and I'm gonna
hit enter, that's going to go ahead and create
our app. So then we can type Git remote dash V,
and we can see where we're pushing to, so
get to Heroku COMM And then we're pushing
that application we just created. So let's type
git push Heroku Master, hit Enter. And finally,
this is going to push everything to Heroku. And
I actually just realized we're missing a crucial
file here. So I'm going to let this finish up
and it's not going to work. And I will show you
why in just a second. All right, so it finished
but It's not going to work, I'm going to go ahead
and open it up anyways, I'm just going to copy
that into a browser, type that in and hit Enter,
and we get an application error. Why do we get an
application error? Well, we're missing a file that
tells Heroku what to do with all these files, I
pretty much just pushed a directory of files and
Heroku is just kind of sitting there. twiddling
its thumbs not knowing what to do with them. So
we got to tell it what to do with them. So we
need to create a file called a proc file. So
I'm just gonna go ahead and pipe touch proc file
with a capital P, there's no extension, it's just
proc file. And then we need one line. It's really
short web colon gunicorn. So we're going to call
that library we installed. Well, it's not really
a library. And so it creates a web server. And
then we need to tell it, what file to create a
web server for. So our app file app colon app.
And that's it. So now if we get add everything,
git commit, dash m, added proc file, git push
Roku Master, hit Enter. And now it should work. So
I'm going to go ahead and let this do its thing.
And then when I return, hopefully, we'll have a
working web app on the internet. All right, so
here we go. Let's go ahead and check this out. And
there you have it. Well, we should probably make
sure it works first. So I'm gonna go ahead and
add do the dishes. Looks like it popped up there.
See if update works, do the dishes and eat some
broccoli. Looks like that's working. Let's see
if we can delete it. And there we go. Looks like
everything's working. And as you can see, this is
running on HTTPS at our application URL. So this
is running on a live web server. Alright, thanks,
everyone for watching. That does it. This Git
repository will be available. Hopefully, it'll be
in the description. I hope you learned something.
I hope it was helpful. And I'll see you around.